look at you little versace duo going on
here today so this is madonna's old
dress
they brought they they brought it out
and gave it to maisie
what you are wearing madonna wow
it's a big day to be made to peters
today it's a big one i'd say it's a huge
day young lady and here you are making
your vma debut as the plus one of mr ed
sheeran over here
big day big day
what did you see in maisie why did you
want to take her in put her to your
label and mentor this i had loads of
mutual friends
kept working with maisie and kept
playing her music to me and
it just happened very very naturally we
worked together uh actually before
before we did we did the deal we wrote
some songs together and her album just
came out it would have gone number one
but kanye dropped on sunday so we got we
got number two so inconsiderate cut well
but it's it's good it's a great great
start so kanye b and kanye i tell you
what but congratulations maisie job well
done what is the best advice this
gentleman here has provided you
it's got it well it's actually been
given today what's that it's really
important i would encourage you to take
it on two it's don't drink things with
sombrero hats as lids
probably gonna get you too far gone
and that's good advice for tonight i
think we should all take that on board
honey that is solid advice is that
advice you will be
is that advice you'll be passing on we
were talking today uh
because you know we like we might we
might go out afterwards and i was like
with with tequila
like just be careful with it sometimes
that can really really take it over the
top you know for things like this how
are you finding fatherhood ed
yeah it's it's amazing it's incredible
it's incredible she's uh she's won now
and uh i fly back in two days and yeah
looking forward to it diaper duty
on the daily absolutely absolutely i
mean like that's that's like the one
thing that men can do at the beginning
is just all the diapers amen to that aim
into that but you're also coming through
with some new music for your fans
shivers your performance
[Music]
there you go how does that feel it feels
great it feels great yeah thank you guys
thank you well i've been a long time
since you've heard that huh no it's the
10 year anniversary of that of that
album so i did i played
it all in full last last week but yeah
new music october 29th the album's
coming out equals shivers has just come
out maisie's album you signed up for
this is out now
please check it out a new side of you
that we're seeing with this album
yeah well you know i kind of i i got
married i became a father i lost a
really close friend and turned 30. so i
feel like it's uh
coming to terms album yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i love seeing your friendship
with courtney cox and the two of you you
know doing your duets and your
collaborations might we see an actual
song come out in the near future of the
two of you yeah easily she sings i'm
pretty sure she sings on backing vocals
on the album i think she's on i think
she's some visiting hours if not she was
definitely on uh
divide somewhere
are you for real well my producer and
songwriter johnny uh work like is it
works for them
dating her don't know me and johnny me
and johnny wright most we wrote shape of
you together we wrote bad habits
together like we we work together a lot
she's really on the background i think
so i think she's on
yeah really i think she is i no no i no
i think she is mate jimmy jimmy carr the
comedian is on the background yeah oh my
maisie's like no rage you're really
gullible
i think true or i'm really gullible as
well
i'm so excited for you though and you've
got a great mentor right here i do i'm
very confident thank you have fun
tonight
yes ma'am no sombreros
that's right thank you so much